Mark Anthony gets emotional over the  death of Juan Gabriel the 47 year old  singer broke down crying over his friend  during his concert on Sunday night at  the Radio City Music Hall in New York  City  the legendary Mexican singer died at age  66 in Santa Monica California earlier  that day  the concert goer tells ET that Anthony  was quote incredibly emotional and told  the crowd that the first time he saw  Juan perform it was on the same stage he  was playing on that night the Grammy  winner also took to Instagram to pay his  respects to the singer and his legacy  posting this pic along with the touching  caption today the world of Latin music  has lost a giant an icon and a legend  that marked my life forever he is  largely responsible for my career  hugely sad with the news of the loss of  one of my heroes your music and your  legacy will be with us forever  rest in peace my light